Das war's für heute.
Vielen Dank für's Zuschauen.
Also wenn ich mir früher ein 37 jährigen vorgestellt habe, dann habe ich mir das nicht so vorgestellt
Ja, moin leute. Ich mache mal meine vm grad an, wo wir gerade dabei sind
Und meine vm, wie die coolen leute sagen, wir haben einen auf der arbeit, der sagt nicht vm, der sagt immer vm
Klingt irgendwie ein bisschen hängen geblieben, ich weiß aber
Wobei, das stimmt nicht mehr, der ist gar nicht mehr bei uns auf der arbeit, der ist mittlerweile
Hat eine eigene firma firma gegründet, ist jetzt woanders als beratungsstelltyp
Aber da hat er immer gesagt, we am und er hat auch nicht vm, wo er gesagt, sondern immer gesagt, we am, we are
we am
Wo ist denn hier meine, meine vm, da
We am, genau, naja, der w kann es ja nicht sein, weil w
Würden die amis ja w aussprechen, also vm müsste eigentlich bei den, bei den amis wie w sein
Wie bescheuert ist eigentlich, dass w w ausgesprochen wird, ja alles andere kannst du irgendwie betonen
Aber das w
Was haben die sich dabei gedacht
Kona style
Gut, da sucht man, da sucht man den sinn ja vergebens
Das hat sich halt so entwickelt
Ja wusste, dir woher das wort planet kommt
Also wie ich jetzt darauf komme, muss ich muss ich mal erzählen, ich habe letztens ein video geguckt auf youtube
Interview mit einem flat earther
Und der typ, der war geil, der hat gesagt
Das ist doch klar, passt mal auf big brain, big brain move, der hat gesagt, das ist doch klar, dass das alles flach ist
Beim wort planet, das ist plan
Planet, man erkennt doch schon, dass das flach ist
Und da habe ich geguckt, kommt das nicht aus dem griechischen
Da habe ich geguckt, doch doch, das kommt aus griechischen, hat mit plan überhaupt nichts zu tun
Überzeugt komplett, ja
Ihr wisst ja, was ich mal gerne sehen würde für ein video
Flat earth, also flach Erde versus hohle Erde
Da würde ich mich mal interessieren, was dabei rauskommt
Die können, die können doch gar nicht auf den gemeinsamen nenner kommen
Weil um hohl zu sein, muss die Erde schon mal rund sein und hohl
Und flat, das passt überhaupt nicht, das, das würde ich gerne, das würde ich gerne mal gucken
Flach Erde versus wie das gibt es, ne das kann ich mir nicht angucken
Das, also ich würde, ich auf der einen Seite würde ich mir das gerne mal angucken
Das, also ich würde es, ich auf der anderen Seite würde ich es gerne gucken
Aber da platzt bestimmt mein Kopf dabei, wenn ich, wenn ich das sehe
IQ++, ja
Huge
8 Monate, dankeschön für den sub, hyper sub, ne noch nicht ganz, noch normaler sub
Ehh, ich mach mal kurz hier meine VM an, meine VM, sorry, meine VM mach ich an
Wer im Innen lebt, was weiß ich, wahrscheinlich gab es da nicht mal so ein Film, dass die Nazis
überlebt haben im Inneren der Erde oder sowas
Das ist hier irgendwie so eine Verarschung
Oder, oder war das auf dem Mond, ok, ja ich bin da nicht so im Bilde was da angeht
Was ist WMHWDB, ah, echt ich hab schon alles geupdatert, das hätte ich gar nicht gedacht
Ah cool, ich hab meine Mail geschrieben, Foggers
Mittlerweile ist das Menü von Thunderbird so unübersichtlich, wie kann ich jetzt als
Unread wieder einstellen, ok, wunderbar, sonst vergesse ich das morgen
Ja, mach mal Update hier, wobei wir brauchen die Linux Kiste eigentlich gar nicht, fällt
ich grad aus, wir machen doch, wir machen doch, wir machen doch Windows Stellzweider
Warum ist das nicht verknüpft, Overlaychamp, hallo, hallo, warum startet das nicht, willst
du mal starten, ist das deinstalliert, hä, hä, was ist das jetzt, warum ist das einfach
weg, warte, warte, warum ist das, ich hab das nicht deinstalliert oder so, das ist noch
da, vielleicht Upgrade, ah ja vielleicht Upgrade, das kann sein, warum macht es dann aber kein
neues Icon wenn Upgrade, wahrscheinlich weil es Windows ist und suckt, kann man das jetzt
hier drüber starten, hä, hä, was zum, ich checke es nicht, wie starte ich das denn jetzt,
warum ist das weg, warum ist das einfach, warum hat sich das einfach gelöscht, Ryna
64, was, warte mal, warte mal, warte mal, warte mal, als admin start, was zum Teufel
ist das, warum ist, warum ist mein Rider weg, das ist doch offensichtlich, offensichtlich
ist es doch noch da, noch da, hat jemand eine klarreiche Idee, nee ich hab es nicht über
Toolbox installiert, ich hab es direkt so installiert, ich installiere es jetzt einfach nochmal,
ich installiere es jetzt einfach nochmal, dann geht es bestimmt wieder, oder ich installiere
es jetzt über die Toolbox, ich installiere, komm, Standalone Installer, gibt es das über
Vingate, nee Vingate hab ich nicht drauf, da hier, Excel, gibt es ja auch cool Leute,
die sagen nicht Excel, die sagen EXE, ist das eigentlich so P-Pro-Fat, komm mal früher,
das hätte gerade mal auf eine CD gepasst, das verstehe ich nicht, aber warum hat sich
das jetzt deinstalliert, das verstehe ich nicht, wo ist das, das Checker, das ist mir zu hoch,
das ist mir zu, das ist Windows Logik, CD 400 MB, nein, nein, CD ist 750 MB und warum
ist die CD 750 MB, weil die erste CD von Sony, Beethovens fünfte, Symphonie oder sowas
enthalten musste und das war genau 72 oder 74 Minuten, ich glaube sogar 72 waren's, weiß
es nicht genau, das kommt umgerechnet auf 750 MB, das ist Boomerwissen, heute interessiert
das keinen mehr, so, ich installiere das jetzt nochmal, vielleicht darf ich dann, darf ich
dann wieder starten, weiß ja nicht, ok, ja ist gut, ich installiere, Next, Select, Uninstall,
ehrlich gesagt, ich will das gar nicht an ins, ja ok wunderbar, Silently, wunderbar, mach
Silently, jetzt mach mal 1,5, ok, ich hab legit keine Ahnung was da Sache ist, sehr
spitz, immer gut, ach 650, waren's nicht 750, waren 650 sogar, kann sein, wie schnell ist
ein Internetleitung, ähm, ähm, ähm, ähm, gute Frage, 440 ab oder 540 ab, eins von beiden,
ich hab mir übrigens jetzt den Kram gekauft, ich hab mir jetzt hier dieses Package gekauft
letztens erst, Store, Desktop, wo ist es denn, Bye, All Products Pack hab ich mir letztens
gekauft, fürs Jahr, das geht schon, eigentlich ist 250 für ein Jahr durchaus ok, das verwendet
man fast jeden Tag und es ist echt gute Software, so ich hoffe jetzt geht der Kram wieder, Run,
ahja, jetzt funktioniert's, alles klar, jaja, jaja, ich hab's mir ja gekauft, ich könnte
jetzt eigentlich mit dem Key mich anmelden, egal, wir wollen jetzt, wir wollen jetzt ja
mal weitermachen, ok, scheint zu funktionieren, alles klar, wo sind wir stehen geblieben,
ich mach mal ruhig das Studio auf, hatten wir irgendwelche Memory Leaks, nee das geht
nicht mit Key, das geht mit, also ich glaube es geht auch noch mit Key, aber man lockt sich
da ein mit Account und Passwort, also da ist es tatsächlich schwierig was zu leaken, weil
man das jetzt nicht im Klartext irgendwie, irgendwie, mal gucken ob wir einen Memory Leak
haben zum Schluss und ob der Kram noch funktioniert hat, genau, das hat ganz hart weirdchamped,
weirdchamped, weirdchamped mit oder ohne Memory Leak, sag, weirdchamped ohne Memory Leak, ok
alles gut, wunderbar, hab ich Subs übersehen Leute, ich guck einfach mal bei mir kurz im
Dashboard, vielleicht mal kurz, ah nee, Overlay hab ich gesehen, Fatal hat gestern 25 Monate
Subscribed, weiß nicht ob er da ist, aber easy as fuck, mega Hyper Subscription hier,
also ich zeig euch mal wo wir stehen geblieben sind, also was schon funktioniert ist, das
GIF als Overlay, wir machen das mit dem Papagei, das ist mir lieber, Content, wo ist der Papagei
Leute, ich brauch irgendwas motivierendes jetzt, in Ryder gibt es da das Menü Resharper,
ja, ja, ja, du kannst Memory Profile machen, wenn du es mit dem Debugger startest, aber
ich bin noch ein bisschen auf Kriegsfuß mit dem Ryder Debugger, jawoll, passt, High Performance
Rare Parrot funktioniert, alles klar, perfekt, easy, also da sind wir stehen geblieben, da
sind wir stehen geblieben bei ungefähr 1000 FPS GIF, so, was ich jetzt probieren werde
ist, der Memory Leak ein bisschen oder, nee das kann sein, dass ich das erst einpendel,
das pendelt sich ein, also was ich heute mal probiert, das ist der ekligste Source Code
glaube ich, den ich je fabriziert habe hier, das ist alles in einer Datei und alles untereinander
und absolut unverständliche, kryptische DirectX Dinger, ich habe keine Ahnung was da abgeht,
wir werden das jetzt ein bisschen ordentlich machen und wir machen das Multithreader, zumindest
ist das mein Plan, also mein Plan für heute ist, wir machen den Decoder und das Renderding
per DirectX machen wir in zwei verschiedene Threads, wir machen also quasi einmal Bilder
zu Grafikkarten, Kopierthread und einmal GIF Decoder und wenn wir ganz schlau sind, und
wenn wir ganz schlau sind heute, dann machen wir das sogar so, dass ich nicht permanent
das GIF von meiner Festplatte lese, ich bin mir nicht sicher, hat der Task Manager eine
IO Anzeige, was ist das hier mal, hier guck mal da, na gut es ist gecashed, es ist gecashed,
aber der macht trotzdem jedes mal, also der liest das immer von der Festplatte, das ist
auch nicht schön, es ist auf jeden Fall sinnvoller, wenn ich das im RAM behalte bei einem GIF und
dann wenn das alles funktioniert und wir wissen, dass das Huge Mega Big Brain Performance ist,
dann machen wir es mal so, dass man das auch verwenden kann, weil aktuell ein GIF mit 1000
FPS braucht ja kein Mensch, wir gucken dann wie lange so ein Durchlauf braucht und machen
dann auch mal einen Sleep rein, so sieht ein Source Code immer aus, ja ganz wichtig ist
ja auch der Source Code, der muss ja so gut dokumentiert sein, dass da quasi, ne der muss
so gut geschrieben sein, dass der sich selbst dokumentiert, also zum Beispiel ist es wichtig,
dass man die Variablen Plup nennt, Temp, ne das ist gar nicht Temp, Plup Temp, E ist
sehr beliebt, Count Temp 2, also gerade Count und Temp 2, da weiß man sofort Bescheid wenn
man das sieht, Data und Size ist auch immer gut, Plup sowieso, ja also Leute ich lese
das heute, ich habe keinen Plastenschimmer, wenn man was es macht, macht aber nichts,
wir räumen jetzt ein bisschen auf, wir räumen jetzt mal ein bisschen auf, also ich schmeiß
den ganzen Shit erstmal raus, wir machen jetzt mal Big Brain, hab ich hier, hab ich hier
hier Rit, oh nice, ok jetzt, jetzt adde ich aber viel mehr als ich haben will, iiih Rit
ok, Windows, ZEG, ich mach mal ein ordentliches Terminal auf, so, wo muss ich hin, CD, Rider,
dann haben wir Overlay Champ und da muss ich Git das Git Repo löschen, Git, so ich hab
da irgendwie Mist, ich hab da irgendwie Mist, Mist, also Git in it, so und jetzt brauch
ich ein Git Ignore, ein ordentliches Git Ignore, ja gab es noch so eine coole Seite, die hab
ich euch am letzten extra noch gezeigt, Git Ignore, GitHub, da gab es so einen fertigen
GitHub, Git Ignore Vorlage, der war auch ganz praktisch, wobei brauchen wir nicht, ist eigentlich
ziemlich sinnlos, was weiß ich, ob es da eine Vorlage für gibt, Git Ignore eigentlich,
.io, stimmt,.io muss das sein, wir haben 169 Zuschauer, Alter das ist laggy,.net brauchen
wir wahrscheinlich, ne, hallo,.net Core, ok und jetzt, ok das brauchen wir, der Rest
ist eigentlich ziemlich, ziemlich unsinnig, aber ok, also Git, Git Ignore, Git, hab ich
da ein Wim drin, boah, Alter jetzt aber advanced hier, äh, Dings und FFmpeg kommt rein, gut,
das reicht eigentlich schon, mach das alles äußerst ungern,.vs können wir auch noch
rein machen und Punkt, ok, perfekt, das sieht doch jetzt eigentlich ganz gut aus, ok, Git
Add minus A, oh nein, Windows Git, Alter, Git Commit minus A minus M, Keg W, perfekt,
so, jetzt hab ich das nämlich in meiner, in meiner Git List zu sehen, jetzt kann ich den
ganzen, den ganzen Shit, den ich hier unten hab, kann ich jetzt einfach löschen und, und
gut ist, so, schnell mit xml schreiben, was, xml, also egal was es ist, xml ist in der
Regel nicht die Lösung dafür, ok, also fangen wir mal an, oh guck mal, ich hab schon ein
paar Klassen angelicht, Videodecoder, Videodecoder brauchen wir, Videoframe brauchen wir auch,
also, wir machen jetzt den Decoder Multithreader, das bedeutet wir brauchen erstmal, Musik
zu laut, passt, so, das heißt wir brauchen jetzt erstmal eine Klasse, wo wir einen Bild
von dem Gift drin halten können, also quasi ein Bild davon, was wir gerade 1000, 1000
FPS haben, einmal ein Bild, ein Bild, so, das benutzen wir ja grad schon, nur mit dem
Unterschied, dass, das ergibt überhaupt keinen Sinn, was ich hier mache, warum hab ich denn
keinen Memory Leak, kann das sein, dass ich, ich verwende die Klasse noch gar nicht, ich
hab wirklich alles in einer Datei, kann das sein, alles unter, ach du, ach du Scheiße,
ok, ich hab's wahrscheinlich letzten Stream gesagt, ich verstehe nicht mehr, was ich gemacht
hab, aber ich muss sagen, es ist heute eingetreten, ich verstehe nicht mehr, was ich gemacht hab,
der Qtbot schickt keine Benachrichtigungen, weirdchamp, lul, richtig weirdchamp, also dann,
dann machen wir das mal, dann versuchen wir das mal ordentlich zu machen, ich schmeiß
diesen ganzen Shit hier raus, so, wir machen das jetzt, das brauchen wir, dass das Fenster
ist, so, und dieser ganze Mist hier, pass mal auf, das machen wir jetzt so, bam, auscommentated,
das kommt weg, und das ist das ganze Diret X Zeug, das muss auch weg, ok, ich kommentier's
erst mal nur aus, dass ich, dass ich's gleich wieder finde, ok, so, jetzt krieg ich ein
leeres Fenster, wenn ich das starte, oder, leeres Fenster, leeres Fenster, ok, perfekt,
jetzt können wir anfangen, also, ich brauch ein Videoframe, das hier ist der FFmpeg,
das hier ist also quasi das unmanaged FFmpeg Ding, dann brauch ich Höhe, Breite, Größe
von einer, einer Bildzeile, und ein Pointer auf die Bilddaten, ok, das passt eigentlich,
das ist eigentlich ganz sinnvoll, das einzige, was ich jetzt noch machen muss, ich muss dafür
sorgen, dass der Kram automatisch aufgeräumt wird, so, und da verwenden wir jetzt mal was
für, was man normalerweise in C Sharp relativ selten verwendet, wir verwenden mal das Gegenteil
von einem Konstraktor, sondern wir verwenden mal einen Destructor, also sprich, wenn der
Garbage Collector das Ding aufräumt, dann ruft er das Ding hier auf, und was wir hier
machen müssen ist, alle managed Ressourcen freigeben, die wir haben, so, und managed Ressourcen
sind in dem Fall, das unmanaged FFmpeg Zeug, also von der Idee her müsste das dann sowas
sein, mal wieder Partner Programming, ich hab mit dem nur in letzter Zeit wenig Kontakt
gehabt, der hat aber auch keine, ich wollte den jetzt auch nicht nerven, dann auch keine
Videos hochgeladen, ich glaube, der ist grad studiumsmäßig oder wie auch immer anderweitig
beschäftigt, weiß ich nicht, aber ich würde tatsächlich gerne weitermachen, dass da was
vorzeigbares rauskommt, Medgill, genau, ja, sag ich, ich mag den Smiley, oder Smiley,
das war jetzt richtig, richtige Boomer, ich sag keine Smiley Emotes, Reissjam Bugfix Session,
soll ich euch mal ehrlich was sagen, soll ich mal real talk, ich hab keinen Bock mehr
am Reissjam was zu machen, ich weiß nicht, warum es keine Ankündigung im Discord gab,
der Bot ist dead wahrscheinlich, ich hab keinen Bock mehr am Reissjam was zu machen irgendwie,
guck mal, das letzte Changeshok ist nicht umsonst vom Februar, der Reissjam hat ja eigentlich
seine Aufgabe erfüllt, es gibt ja mittlerweile wieder Hardware, lass es die Community machen,
kannst vergessen, die Community macht da wahrscheinlich gar nichts, die Community ist nur scharf auf
mein Frontendkram wahrscheinlich, mein BigBrain Javascript Zeug, ich weiß nicht ob ich am
Reissjam nochmal was mache, keine Ahnung, also mein aktuell funktioniert der noch, auch
das ist natürlich nicht so ganz richtig, was passiert denn da wenn ich da drauf klicke,
wo komme ich denn da raus, oh die Expertseite ist richtig schnell, nicht lieferbar, ok nicht
lieferbar ist ungleich 1799 Euro, ok dann ist der Website ein Paser im Arsch, keine Ahnung,
da müsste ich den mal, ich müsste mal den, wie heißt das Ding, den Street Merchant rebasen,
aber ich hab keinen Bock am Reissjam was zu machen, ich sag's euch wie es ist, ausgechampft
erstmal, ja das Gute ist ja ich hab damals ja schon versucht ein bisschen mitzudenken
und ich hab keinen selbst programmiert, sondern ich nehme einen den es auf GitHub gibt, die
sind leider ein bisschen langsam was die deutschen Jobs angeht, naja wir machen heute erstmal
ein bisschen Gift Overlay, iDisposable verwenden das könnte man machen, aber da muss ich mich
ja trotzdem selbst darum kümmern das zu disposen, AvFrame Release, nee, Free, ok so müsste das
eigentlich funktionieren, an dem Moment das muss ja unsaves, warum, was hat das für Schmerzen,
is not assignable, oh Pointerstells, Pointerstells und das geht jetzt aber so nicht, also brauchen
wir unsere schöne Temp Variable wieder, weil Temp der beste Name ist für alles, so perfekt,
so und jetzt von der Idee her räumt er das FFmpeg Zeug automatisch auf, bin mir nicht
so ganz sicher ob das so funktioniert, aber von der Idee her müsste das eigentlich funktionieren,
wir haben Mods da, wir haben Mods da, je dass wir Mods da haben die sagen bloß grad nichts,
Mod Check, ok also jetzt können wir hier unser FFmpeg Zeug drin speichern, jetzt müssen wir
bloß, das stimmt noch übrigens gar nicht was ich da mache, ich muss sagen FFmpeg Frame
Clone oder sowas, Frame Clone, ah hier, weil FFmpeg handelt die Videodaten tatsächlich
relativ clever, also das heißt Finalizer, stimmt, das heißt glaube ich schon immer so,
jetzt wo du sagst ich glaube das heißt seit Anfang an in C-Sharp so, Destructor ist, ihr
seht ich hab so viel C++ Zeug gemacht, das hat sich bei mir in den Kopf eingebrannt obwohl
ich das eigentlich gar nicht will und ich C++ absolut nicht mag, aber es gibt so ein paar
C++ Sachen die merkt man sich anscheinend, so also FFmpeg macht das relativ Big Brain,
das Management von Bilderdaten, also ich versuche euch das mal kurz zu zeigen an der Stelle,
also wenn man hier mit FFmpeg einen Frame decoded, also in dem Fall den GIF Frame decoded,
dann legt FFmpeg für einen unter der Haube einen Buffer im RAM an wo die RGB, also wo
das Bild drinne steht, so nachdem FFmpeg weiß, dass Memory Handling oder generell immer
wieder Sachen erstellen und löschen und erstellen relativ ineffizient ist, kann man FFmpeg sagen,
das soll das nur löschen, den Buffer im RAM, wenn er es nicht mehr verwendet wird, also
quasi macht FFmpeg ein bisschen sowas wie Garbage Collection, nur muss man es von Hand
machen, indem man ihm sagt, ok FFmpeg Frame unref, der hat internen Counter und du musst
es quasi referenzieren und dann wird internen Counter plus eins gerechnet und wenn du es
unrefst wird es minus eins gerechnet, wenn es bei null ist, gibt FFmpeg den Speicher frei
von so einem Bild, da muss man sich nicht mehr selbst darum kümmern, das heißt was
ich jetzt machen muss, ich muss sicher gehen, dass es unreferenziert wird und dann alles
gelöscht ist, so das müsste eigentlich passen, das referenziert, das unreferenziert und löscht
den Kram, das müsste so weit eigentlich passen, so jetzt kommt das eigentlich kompliziert,
einfach den Decoder für GIFs. Ich weiß, dass wir Modstar haben, ich habe
ja mein Creator Dashboard. Wisst ihr was? Wir haben keine Modstar. Modcheck, wo sind
sie alle hin? Und wenn, und wenn sich gar so sehr einer daneben
benimmt, das kommt ja nie vor, wir wissen ja, der Chat ist eigentlich immer relativ
verträglich hier, das kann ich ihn auch von Hand bannen, kein Problem. Doppelmodcheck
sogar. So, also wir brauchen jetzt den Multi-Threaded
Decoder für GIFs. Gut, auf gehts, Leute, jetzt. So, den machen wir aber iDisposable,
ich lasse ihn auf, iDisposable, also ich lasse ihn irgendwie, falls ich den, falls ich das
brauche mal, ach komm, scheiß drauf, memory leak, FTW, gut, also wir haben unsere FFmpeg
Zeug ein bisschen gerappt. So, also GIF Decoder, das können wir uns
kopieren von dem, was wir hier eklig zusammengewurstet haben das letzte Mal. Also wir brauchen irgendwas
um die Bilder zu decoden vom GIF. Also, wir nehmen ja dieses GIF hier und dieses GIF hat,
wer kann schnell zählen, wie viele Bilder hat das GIF? Was meint ihr, wie viele Bilder
hat das GIF? Also ich meine nicht FPS, aus wie vielen
Bildern es insgesamt besteht. Ich hab keine Ahnung, wenn ich ehrlich bin,
kann das FF Probe, kann das FF Probe? Sagt es einem an, wie viele Bilder man hat?
GIF 25 FPS, das heißt ja nicht, wie viele Bilder es insgesamt sind, ok, das müssen
wir mal gucken, FF Probe, GIF Image Count, Patch Frame Count, perfekt.
GIF, what? Alles klar Leute, Obvious Command, natürlich,
natürlich. Das ist total klar, ups, falsch die Mode.
Was auch immer das macht, mal gucken, ob das jetzt überhaupt funktioniert.
10, 10 Leute, 10, 10, haben wir. Alles klar, aber Count Packets ist falsch,
Count Packets, Count Packets stimmt nicht. Pound Count Frames, ach du Scheiße, das ist
ja viel komplizierter, als ich mir das vorgestellt habe.
Calculate it based on time instead, oh, oh Leute, exquisite, nee, nee, nee, nee, das mach
ich jetzt nicht. Ok, 10, ich geh ja verfassen 10, 10 Frames,
alles gut, 10 ist, wir werden es ja gleich sehen, wir werden es ja gleich selbst sehen,
also wahrscheinlich, wahrscheinlich 10 Frames. Alter, was ist das denn für, ist das Dings,
ist das ähm, ist das nicht mein Genres Mask oder, ist, a link between words, genau,
Bettge. Ah ok, also machen wir mal irgendwas public,
natürlich unsave, was sonst, how to check the speed of, speed weiß ich, den speed weiß
ich, der speed ist 25 fps, ich will wissen aus wieviel einzel Bilder das GIF besteht,
also unsave, so wie nennen wir das Ding, Public, unsave, was weiß ich, Read Frames, so, bool
loop ist defaultmäßig true, kann ja auch sein, dass ich mein GIF nur einfach anzeigen
will, vielleicht braucht man das, äh, what, also what, read frames true, so und dann brauchen
wir noch irgendwie die Möglichkeit das zu cancel, cancellation token, gleich, so, setzen
wir auch leer, also sprich defaultmäßig wird das einfach endlos schleif und gut ist,
VLC, stimmt, im VLC könnten wir nochmal gucken, ob der VLC da was anzeigt, das ist tatsächlich
auch eine gute Idee, VLC, VLC kann das GIF gar nicht abspielen,
der nightbot ist kaputt, VLC ist, VLC ist kaputt, was zeigt ein VLC an, bei tools, media information,
frame rate 10, ok, also, guck dir mal, VLC kommt mit dem GIF nicht klar, windows photo
kann das, ja, aber windows photo kann dir nicht anzeigen, aus wieviel Einzelbildern
das besteht, oder, das wird mich äußerst verwundern, ne, natürlich nicht, was sonst,
also, dass windows photo überhaupt irgendwas kann, wird mich schon wundern, Quatsch, kein
Problem, wir kriegen das doch gleich selbst raus, ich wollte bloß gucken, ob es ffprobe
irgendwie kann, so, also, read frames, so und jetzt können wir uns den kran zusammen
kopieren, als erstes, wir wollen das ganze ja multithread machen, also, task, task, run,
bam, so, neuen task starten, weil, true, lul, beste, beste, erstmal eine Endlosschleife,
checkw, so, mal gucken, ob das funktioniert, wenn ich das jetzt starte, true, lulw, genau,
so, also, jetzt brauchen wir hier sowas, wo gehts denn hier überhaupt los, jetzt brauchen
wir sowas wie decoder gleich, oh ne, wir machen das, wir machen das ab, machen das ab, mach
alles aus, private void, start render, lulw, lulw, lulw, lulw, lulw, lulw, lulw, lulw,
lulw, lulw, lulw, lulw perfekt, so, und da, machen wir jetzt mal hier, decoder, video
decoder, und, ja, decoder, read frames, das ergibt so keinen Sinn, was ich da mache,
weiß ich auch. Ich will bloß mal gucken, ob das so alles tut, was ich, was ich, was ich
gemacht hab. Ah Moment, Moment, Moment. Moment, das stimmt ja gar nicht, was ich hier mache.
Hier muss ich auch noch ein Thread starten. Wo ist das vorher, das vorher erstellte Nassi-Schneidermann-Diagramm?
Ähm, ich dachte, das machst du. Man muss das üben. Man muss das einfach nur oft genug
üben. Du kannst uns das ja dann in der, so in der halben Stunde im Stream vorstellen.
Können wir per Discord gucken. Natürlich schwierig. Das ist übrigens auch ein Grund, warum ich
diese ganze Struktogramm-Kacke teilweise so bescheuert finde. Es ist unglaublich schwierig,
den Struktogramm zu erstellen. Für was, wenn du selbst noch keine Ahnung hast, wie es eigentlich
aussehen soll. Also das, was da teilweise in der Berufsschule erzählt wurde. Ich mein, ich konnte,
ich hab ja angefangen hier mit, mit, mit Programmieren seit, keine Ahnung, 2002 oder so. Also ich
machte das schon eine ganze Weile. Also mir war sogar in der Berufsschule, ich hab ja die
Ausbildung später gemacht. Ich konnte ja zu dem, zu dem Zeitpunkt schon ganz, ganz brauchbar
programmieren. Ähm, mir war das damals in der Berufsschule schon bewusst, was das für ein Mist
ist. Und, ähm, die Lehrer dann ernsthaft behauptet haben, so nach dem Motto, ja, erstmal, erstmal
Struktogramm, so dumm. Niemand, also niemand macht wirklich Struktogramme, das kommt ja noch dazu.
Struktogramme ist total, also Nasty Schneidermann Struktogramme sind total sinnlos. Also selbst der
Ersteller, der Erfinder hat ja gesagt, das ist eigentlich sinnlos. Und generell war Programmieren
in der Berufsschule unglaublich bescheuert. Das ist einfach, einfach dumm. Programmieren in der
Berufsschule hat man gesehen, wie viele unfähige Leute hier am Start sind. So, also von der Idee
her will ich jetzt sowas hier machen. Also, passt mal auf, passt mal auf. Von der Idee her will ich sowas machen. For each, Frame,
Decoder Read Frames, ähm, ähm, Private Void Draw Bitmap. So, ich weiß, dass das so nicht
funktioniert, aber so von der Idee her will ich das, will ich das machen. Ja, ok, also.
So weit, so weit von der Idee her. So, weil das würde dann heißen, wenn das, wenn das so funktioniert,
wie ich mir das vorstelle. Das heißt, ich habe hier einen eigenen Thread. Das brauchen wir nicht mehr. Alter, was ist hier los?
Ja, ich habe hier einen eigenen Thread. Ich muss halt nur gucken, wie ich das, wie ich das von da hier,
hier raus bekomme. Moment mal, ergibt das überhaupt Sinn, was ich da mache? Es ergibt doch gar keinen
Sinn, was ich da mache, oder? Habe ich hier einen eigenen Thread? Nee, ich muss das in irgendeine
Warteschlange schreiben. Ich muss das in irgendeine, in irgendeinen Buffer schreiben, von dem ich das
dann hier rauslese. Wenn ich jetzt hier einf, nee, nee, sonst bringt das ja nichts. Dann funktioniert das.
Weil dann hat er hier einen Thread gestartet. Dann kriegt er hier aus irgendeiner Warteschlange ein neues Bild.
CD, EFC, das, das, das, das ist garantiert irgendein Hexcode für irgendein Pfeil, oder? So was wie
Kaffee, Babe, Bayava. Was ist das? Okay, ist es anscheinend doch nicht, aber hätte ich jetzt, hätte ich jetzt vermutet.
Welches Pfeil ist das? Aber danke schön für den Prime-Sub, by the way. Massive-Sub. Nur Buchstabenfolge,
es würde, es würde als Pfeil-Header durchgehen. Es ist, es ist gültiges, gültiges Hex. Bayava fängt, weiß
ich, ob ihr das wisst, Bayava, Bayava-Pfeil-Header steht drinnen. Binary. Wie heißt denn das richtig?
Ja, genau. Bayava, Bayava steht in dem, was es für ein, was es für ein Pfeil-Typ ist, steht, steht das
drinnen. Kaffee, Babe. Da wollten sie lustig sein, die Java-Leute. Okay, also weiter im Text. Also das
von, das ist von der Idee her eigentlich ganz, ganz sinnig, was ich hier mache. Aber, aber so geht
das, so geht das natürlich nicht. Okay, ich weiß nicht, was ich mache, ehrlich gesagt. Wir basteln
jetzt erstmal den Decoder, der den Kram in seinem eigenen Thread ausgibt. Also, ich will auf jeden
Fall nicht Rückgabewert void. Wir verwenden jetzt mal was ganz Neues, was Massive Big Brain neu ist,
was es erst seit C Sharp 9 gibt. Mal gucken, ob das so funktioniert, wie ich mir das vorstelle. So,
also wir könnten jetzt hier beispielsweise sagen I enumerable Video Frame und dann sowas hier machen,
dass der, ach ne, das geht ja nicht immer. Das geht ja nicht. Ach ne, Yield Return ist es,
ne? Ah ja, genau. So, genau und das geht in Unsafe nicht, stimmt. Das darf man in Unsafe
nicht machen. So war das, genau, so war das. Okay, alles klar. Okay, so. Wir probieren jetzt mal was
ganz Neues aus, was ganz Neues, habe ich selten verwendet und zwar wir probieren jetzt mal Channels
aus. Also von der Idee her ist das jetzt folgendermaßen. Ich versuche das, ich versuche
mal, ich versuche mal zu erklären, was ich mir jetzt denke und ob das funktioniert,
ist dann wieder was anderes. Also wir starten hier einen Extra Thread, der unabhängig läuft
von unserem Fenster. An damit gar nichts zu tun. So, da drin lesen wir jetzt aus dem GIF,
das GIF quasi Bild für Bild ein. Dann schreiben wir das in einen Buffer und diesen Buffer lesen
wir dann hier in dem Renderthread aus. Allerdings so, dass das quasi unabhängig voneinander
läuft. Also nicht so, nicht ein Durchlauf unerwartet hier, sondern dass der das einfach
da reinschreibt und hier, wobei, einfach reinschreiben ist blöd, dann produzieren wir
wahrscheinlich Memory Leak, wenn wir schneller decoden als wir es rendern. Also beschränken
wir den Buffer mal. So, wir verwenden jetzt mal Channels. Channels ist neu, das gibt es erst
seit C-Sharp 8 oder C-Sharp 9. Das ist, sagt Microsoft, die High-Performance-Variante von
was eigentlich? Von Collections für Thread-Kommunikation. Keine Ahnung, was sagt Microsoft denn selbst
zu Channels? Channels. Was sagen die dazu? Channels. Ja, die Channels in Go und die Microsoft
Channels, die haben außerdem Name nicht so wirklich viel gemein. Denn Channel in Go hat
ja auch Syntax, also im Prinzip ist es Kommunikation, also reinschreiben und rauslesen, das ist
das Gleiche, aber Go hat ja komplette Syntax Extensions für Channels, das gibt es ja hier
nicht. So, also was sagen die denn selbst? Was? Microsoft das? Nein, nein, nein, auf Englisch
please. Die neuen Microsoft Docs sind kacke. Ich meine, was soll mir das denn sagen? Channels
support reading and writing of elements. Ja, geil, auf die Idee bin ich auch schon gekommen.
Das ist keine allzu big brain Erklärung. Kann es denn ein Channel-Reader-Return? Doch, doch,
doch, kann ich machen. Wahrscheinlich, wahrscheinlich kann Channel-Reader-Return, ja, das funktioniert.
Kann aber auch, ich probiere das jetzt mal. Also, Videoframe. So, und maximal 10 Stück
im Voraus rendern, das reicht. Wenn ich 10 Stück im Voraus rendere, das hat den Scham,
also mal angenommen, ich würde nur einen rendern und dann war, also nein, ich würde
einen decoden, also ich decode ein Bild, schreibe es hier rein, render das Bild aufs Fenster
und warte dann, ähm, dann profitiere ich ja nicht so wirklich schön vom Multithreading,
oder? Also ich würde sagen, wir machen, der darf einfach mal 10 Frames rendern. Wichtig
ist, äh, decoden. Wichtig ist, dass ich in der richtigen Reihenfolge dann render. Das
sollte ja passen, weil der von Anfang bis Ende das immer nacheinander reinschreibt.
Und, ähm, dadurch, dass ich 10 Frames im Voraus habe, kann ich dann später, wenn ich
hier auch mal auf die normale FPS-Anzahl runtergehen will, also nicht 1000 FPS, sondern 25 FPS,
habe ich dann hier nicht so das Problem mit Timings, weil das eigentliche Rendern ist
in unter einer Millisekunde durch. Dann mache ich da einfach dann Hardcoded Sleep 16 oder
was auch immer, 16 Millisekunden oder was auch immer das ist. Nee, für 25 FPS ist es
was? 40 Millisekunden. 40, 40 Millisekunden Sleep. Dann hat man 25 FPS. Stimmt das was
ich sage Leute? 40 Millisekunden pro Frame sind 25. Ergibt das Sinn? Ich würde sagen
ja, aber so sicher bin ich mir da jetzt auch nicht. Ich glaube schon. Egal. Also, okay,
wir probieren das jetzt mal aus. Gut, ähm, 3 in Error, genau. Also wir haben einen Channel
angelegt, Channel mit 10 Stück. Okay, wir starten ein Task, das heißt jetzt kann ich
mir den ganzen Krempel hier erstmal kopieren von FFmpeg. Zeitdurchfrequenz habe ich gemacht,
wir haben 40 raus. Also 1 durch 25 für 0,04, das sind 40 Millisekunden, das muss dann
stimmen. Okay, also Copy Paste. Das ist, okay. Das brauchen wir auch, das brauchen wir auch,
das brauchen wir auch. Eigentlich brauchen wir das alles bis auf den ganzen Mist da unten.
Okay. Alles klar. Das ist Low Level FFmpeg Zeug, was halt so gemacht werden muss, weil
es sonst nicht funktioniert. So, den Pfad zu unseren Binaries setzen, den Pfad zum Bild,
das ist vielleicht dumm, das Ganze jetzt zu hardcoden, aber ich mein, why not? Was ist
eigentlich unsafe? Naja, also ziemlich alles hier ist unsafe. Allein schon, dass hier
ein Kontextpointer zurückkommt, ist unsafe. Das geht nicht anders. Das ist ein ziemlich
dünner Rapper um FFmpeg. Achso, du meinst, für was unsafe an sich ist. Unsafe ist, dass
ich so Sachen machen kann, wie Pointer verwenden, Referenzen verwenden und Dinger. Ich weiß
es gar nicht, was es noch geht, aber wenn du sobald du Low Level Pointer machen willst,
musst du sagen unsafe. So, und das Dumme ist an unsafe, dass man einige Features nicht
verwenden kann in einem unsafe Kontext. Zum Beispiel Yield Return und sowas, das geht
nicht in unsafe und Async Await geht auch nicht in unsafe. Oh fuck, wenn Async Await
nicht geht, dann kann ich auch keine Channels verwenden. Ach Quatsch, wir warten einfach
synchron. Wer braucht Await? Einfach synchron warten und gut ist. Also, was haben wir denn
jetzt? Bild, Bild, ok. Kontext, Open. Das muss ja funktionieren, weil das ging ja im
anderen auch. So, was brauchen wir als nächstes? Package, Package, Frame. Also ich hab's hier
eben gestartet, das funktioniert. Das heißt, das können wir uns jetzt Copy Pasten aus dem,
was wir eben hatten. So, übrigens, warum ist der hier rot? Weil ich nichts Returne. Ok,
dann sagen wir jetzt hier Return, Return, Channel, Channels, Alter, Channel, Reader.
So, geht das? Ich hoffe mal. Race Condition gibt's nix. Ne, bei uns gibt's nie Bugs. Das
ist doch, also komm, hatten wir schon einmal in einem Stream was, was nicht funktioniert
hat? Ich kann mich nicht erinnern. So, ne. So, also. FFmpeg versteht unter Packet und
Frame folgendes. Also, ich versuch das mal zu erklären. Also FFmpeg ist ja ne Multimedia
Library mit Video-Decodern und Video-Encodern. Also FFmpeg kann ja im Prinzip alles, was
es so gibt, außer was FFmpeg nicht kann. Also FFmpeg kann H264, GIF, Avi-Gedöns, die
unterschiedlichsten Container von MP4 bis MKV bis MOF und sonst wie. Also FFmpeg kann
alles. Das einzige was FFmpeg nicht kann, was halbwegs verbreitet ist, sind, ähm, wie
heißt denn dieses, dieses neue Apple-Bilder-Format? H-H-H-E-I-C oder so? H-Hike? Wisst ihr was
ich mein? Hike-Image? Heißt das Hike? Hier, das da. Genau. Das kann FFmpeg noch nicht.
Aber was FFmpeg kann, ist die Video-Variante davon. Das können sie. Sie können nur die
Image-Variante davon noch nicht. Aber das ist bei FFmpeg alles nur eine Frage der Zeit,
bis es das auch kann. Achso, was Yield macht, das kann ich dir zeigen. Das zeige ich dir.
Ich glaube, da kann ich ein schönes Beispiel basteln. Ich muss mal irgendwie in das Programm
reingehen, was äh, wo nichts passiert, wenn ich starte, weil das ist gerade proppen. Also
was du machen kannst mit Yield-Return ist folgendes. Ähm, wie erkläre ich das jetzt
am besten? Also mal angenommen, du hast eine Liste, die on the fly erzeugt werden soll.
Normalerweise ist es ja so, wenn du, sorry, wir machen jetzt einfach, warte, warte, ich
mache mal, ich zeig dir das, ich mache mal ein eigenes, äh, oder haben wir vielleicht
noch ein Konsolenprojekt, was ich irgendwie... New Project, wir machen das jetzt in Visual
Studio, dann komme ich nicht durcheinander. Äh, Console, ConsoleApplication.net Core,
ConsoleApp 16, ich würde sagen, wir hätten einige, wir hätten einige ConsoleApps gehabt,
aber who cares? So, also ich zeig dir jetzt, was das macht, wenn, wenn Visual Studio da
Bock drauf hat. So, also, ähm, normalerweise, wenn du eine Liste erzeugst, ist das ja relativ
einfach. So, du erzeugst, nein, du erzeugst eine, okay, die sind aber mittlerweile krass
minimalistisch, was Includes angeht, Alter. So, du erzeugst normalerweise eine Liste,
in dem du die Elemente, also, dann ist, die Elemente sind schon bekannt zu dem Zeitpunkt,
also du erzeugst eine Liste und sagst, wir kürzen das mal ab, wir kürzen das mal ab,
also wir sagen jetzt hier 1, 2, 3, 4, 5, 6, 7, ach so, immer, so, das kommt in die Liste
rein. So, und wenn du jetzt die Liste durchlaufen willst, dann muss die Liste schon fertig sein.
So, also zu diesem Zeitpunkt, wenn du das ausgibst, die Liste, dann ist die Liste schon
fertig. Liste, dann ist die Liste schon fertig. Also sprich, die, die ist, die ist komplett,
von Anfang bis Ende. Wenn du jetzt allerdings was hast, was eventuell nie fertig wird oder
on the fly erzeugt werden sollt, oder, oder, oder on the fly erzeugt, machen wir, du willst
eine random Nummer haben. Sagen wir, du willst einen unendlich langen Stream von random Nummern
haben. Das kannst du so nicht machen. Wenn du das in eine Liste schreibst, dann ist die
Liste quasi, die muss, bevor du sie durchläufst, muss die, muss die fertig sein. Aber sagen
wir mal, du willst einen unendlich langen Stream an random Nummern haben. Wie machst
du das? So, natürlich, die einfachste Variante ist, also die, die Variante, die aber nicht
sich gut integrieren lässt, sondern halt einfach alles in einem Blockbrauch ist, du sagst random,
und dann sagst du hier quasi, wild, true, random, next, so, bam. So, das ist, so, jetzt
hast du eine, eine Endlosschleife mit random Nummern. So, das ist jetzt allerdings vielleicht
nicht die allerschönste Variante, weil das ist eine Endlosschleife in deinem Main, und
du kannst das auch von nirgendwo anders aufrufen. Und vielleicht willst du auch gar keine Endlosschleife
haben, vielleicht willst du das auch mal irgendwann abbrechen, oder vielleicht willst du auch
gar nur 100 random Nummern, aber du willst nicht 100 random Nummern im Vorfeld berechnen,
sondern du willst die eine nach dem anderen, und ab 100 ist halt, ist halt Schluss. So,
nehmen wir mal das Beispiel, dann kannst du das, dann kannst du das machen mit yield return,
also du sagst static, generate, random numbers, void ist übrigens falsch, das heißt, an
der Stelle willst du sagen, ok, ich gebe keine Liste zurück, sondern ich gebe ein, ein nummerable
zurück von ins, an der Stelle ist ja noch gar nicht klar, wie viele, wie viele random
Nummern es gibt, also ok, es gibt 100, aber es ist, also du willst die Nummern nicht im
Voraus berechnen. So, jetzt machen wir, jetzt machen wir eine Schleife, dann void, kleiner
100, also wir machen im Prinzip das gleiche wieder oben, machen im Prinzip das, das hat
aber auch einen schönen, das hat aber auch schon einen schönen, einen schönen Nebeneffekt,
yield macht eine Liste, die erzeugt wird, während man drüber iteriert, ja, yield macht gar keine
Liste, yield erzeugt on the fly immer einzelnen Rückgabewert, jedes Mal, wenn du ein, ein,
anfragst. Eine Vorschleife macht ja unter der Haube nichts anderes, wie immer next aufzurufen
bei einem Iterator, und bei dieser next Aufruf sorgt dafür, dass der bei, ich zeig's, ich
zeig's euch, wieder reinspringt und, und das weiter, weitermacht, so. Wenn du jetzt hier
was hast, für 100 random Numbers zu generieren, du willst aber immer nur eine haben, also du
willst nicht im Vorfeld alle 100 erzeugen, normalerweise würdest du jetzt hier eine Liste
machen, war list int list add und dann würdest du sagen return list, was das blöde daran
ist, ich mein das funktioniert, aber was der jetzt macht ist, du generierst jetzt 100 random
Nummern und gibst die zurück, das willst du ja vielleicht gar nicht, vielleicht überleg
dir mal das generieren von so einer random Nummer, würde jetzt 5 Minuten dauern oder
5 Sekunden, das können wir ja mal einbauen, einfach just for fun, nee machen wir nicht,
aber reicht glaube ich, also stell dir mal vor das dauert ein bisschen, das zu generieren,
da willst du das jetzt vielleicht nicht 100 mal im voraus machen, so und jetzt können
wir das Ganze ein bisschen verbessern, wir können jetzt sagen hier, for each generate
100 random Numbers item, so noch werden immer 100 random Numbers, bei dem Aufruf hier von
dieser Funktion, werden 100 random Nummern generiert, in eine Liste geschrieben und die
Liste wird zurückgegeben und erst dann läuft die Schleife, so die effizientere Variante
ist aber die random Nummer immer erst zu jedem Durchlauf zu generieren, anstatt 100 im Vorfeld,
das ist C sharp, so und das macht man jetzt folgendermaßen, man lässt diesen ganzen Listenshit
weg und sagt einfach, yield return random next, so und du wirst sehen, das funktioniert
genauso, aber jetzt funktioniert das folgendermaßen, der ruft sich den iterator ab, also der ruft
sich dieses I enumerable ab, kann man gucken, ob man das hier irgendwie sieht, genau, der
holt sich den oder den enumerator raus und ruft dann quasi pro Durchlauf move next auf,
das ist das, was die Vorschleife unter der, was eine for each Schleife unter der Haupe
macht, also eine for each Schleife ist quasi eine wild Schleife, die move next aufruft
bis falls zurückkommt und das dann in eine Variable schreibt, ist halt syntaktisch ein
bisschen schöner und was der jetzt macht ist, der sagt ok, ich hole mir den iterator, ruft
next auf, so und wenn du next aufrufst, heißt das ok, der geht hier rein, führt das aus
bis zum ersten mal yield return, wenn yield return kommt, springt er zurück, führt den
Schleifenbody aus und beim nächsten next macht er den nächsten Schleifendurchlauf,
das heißt du musst jetzt nicht mehr 100 random nummern im Vorfeld erzeugen, sondern kannst
100 random nummern on the fly erzeugen, während du sie brauchst, was natürlich deutlich angenehmer
ist und das ganze kannst du natürlich auch endlos machen, also wir sagen jetzt mal generate
random numbers und sagen anstatt vor sagen wir einfach while, while true, dann hast du
hier eine endlos stream von random nummern, das ist recht praktisch, man braucht das selten
aber wenn man es braucht ist es wirklich praktisch, das ist halt sinnvoll bei Dingern wo du nicht
weißt wann Schluss ist oder wo vielleicht nie Schluss ist, zum Beispiel stell dir ne
Kamera vor, stell dir ne Kamera vor, von der du Videobilder liest, die hört ja nicht
auf die Kamera, die hat ja im Prinzip unendlich Bilder, praktisch nicht, da irgendwann geht
sie kaputt, aber die hat ja theoretisch unendlich viele Bilder, du kannst ja gar nicht am Anfang
eine Liste mit allen Kamerabildern, die je kommen werden erstellen um die zu verarbeiten,
du brauchst ja nen stream von Kamerabildern, immer dann wenn es halt ne neues Kamerabild
gibt und das könntest du beispielsweise so hier drinnen machen, du würdest dann nicht
random next aufrufen, du würdest dann sagen camera read next frame oder was auch immer,
unten drunter ist dann nen rtsp stream, was auch immer ist ja egal, aber du könntest
über diese ap dann aufrufen, ja also das ist yieldreturn und jetzt kommt die bigprane
variante, es gibt jetzt async einarmorable, das gibt es auch, dann kannst du nämlich sagen,
ich weiß übrigens gar nicht wie die richtige syntax davon ist, und wie war da jetzt die
richtige, man muss das async machen, und dann muss man hier sagen await, ja genau das funktioniert,
und das braucht man für den fall der fälle, das ist auch neu, seit csharp 8 oder so oder
neu, das braucht man für den fall der fälle, dass man hier drinnen await verwenden will,
zum beispiel await task delay 100, 100 millisekunden, oder sagen wir mal ne sekunde, guck du hast
jetzt einen unendlichen stream von random nummern, und wir simulieren jetzt halt hier,
dass es ein bisschen warten muss, das ist mal angenommen, das wäre nicht so schnell,
das random nummern generieren, und jetzt sieht man auch, dass es sinnvoll ist, dass man die
immer nicht alle im vorfeld generieren muss, sondern immer nur eins auf einmal, ja so sieht
es aus, du hast es halbwegs verstanden, ja, das ist die neu, also async, das braucht man
ganz selten, das normale ist schon selten, aber das ist doch ziemlich selten, dass man
das verwendet, das wie gesagt, das verwendet man eigentlich nur, wenn man irgendwelche
eingebauten sachen verwenden möchte, die await und async sind, sonst braucht man das
nicht, hat javascript eigentlich async await von c-sharp geklaut oder andersrum, ja c-sharp
geklaut, ist kein witz, ist so, c-sharp war mit die erste sprache die das hatte, die haben
das geklaut und ich vermute mal, dass das, da bin ich mir aber nicht sicher, das rate
ich jetzt einfach mal, dass das ein bisschen was mit typescript zu tun hatte, weil der
typescript-typ bei microsoft ist der c-sharp erfinder, der hat irgendwann gesagt, ich
habe keinen bock mehr auf c-sharp, wie heißt der anders heilsberg, der hat c-sharp erfunden
auf auftrag von microsoft und jetzt typescript und ich vermute mal, dass es damit zusammen
hängt, dass javascript jetzt auch async await im standard hat, dass die sich gedacht
haben, das ist so eine gute idee, das bauen wir direkt in den standard mit ein, ja vermute
ich, weiß nicht ob das stimmt, keine ahnung, wie weit sind wir aktuell, wir bauen das heute
ordentlich, ich finde das aber auch gut in javascript mit async await, weil ich muss
euch ehrlich sagen, ich habe diese manuelle promise, then, error-geschichte nie richtig
gecheckt, vor allem hast du in javascript, der irgendwann 50, 50 spillionen nestet, then
links und sonst wie was gehabt, also in javascript hast du ja irgendwann so ein ding hier dann,
das war ja nicht unnormal in javascript, dass du sowas hattest hier, da ist das mit async
await schon schöner, ok also wir decoden mal unser gif weiter, ok also, was ich eigentlich
an der stelle sagen wollte, was ffmpeg unter packet und frame versteht, also wie gesagt,
ffmpeg ist ein multimedia framework, mit dem man videos decoden kann, gifs decoden kann,
bilder decoden kann und auch endcoden kann, also alles was man multimedia braucht, ist
ffmpeg eigentlich gut, es gibt eigentlich nur zwei große so open source multimedia frameworks,
die viel verwendet werden, das ist einmal libav, das ist quasi ffmpeg, moment habe ich
das jetzt verwechselt, war libav nicht, ist das ffmpeg, doch ich glaube es ist libav,
das ist einmal ffmpeg und gstreamer, vlc verwendet was eigenes, hat aber glaube die ffmpeg codecs
mit dabei, mplayer auch, genau, und was ffmpeg versteht unter packet und frame ist ein bisschen
schwammig, also wenn du ein video decoden willst, dann geht das in zwei schritten, du liest
mit ffmpeg die datei ein, in dem fall das gif, ffmpeg guckt dann, dass es soweit einliest,
was man von der datei braucht, dass man ein bild decoden kann, das ist ja gar nicht so
einfach, je nach video format, muss man unterschiedlich viel einlesen, dass es ausreicht um ein vollständiges
bild zu decoden, also ffmpeg liest so viel ein wie es einlesen muss in ein packet, also
sprich ein packet ist ein komprimiertes bild, ein komplettes komprimiertes bild in ffmpeg
und ein frame ist ein unkomprimiertes bild, also ein packet ist quasi alle informationen
die ich brauche um ein bild decoden zu können, aber eben noch komprimiert, noch nicht decoded
und ein frame ist das nachdem es decoded ist, also ein frame ist dann, weiß nicht ob es
immer rgb ist, nee ein frame ist das was man ihm angibt, modge, ja kann ich rein machen,
so also ich habe jetzt versucht zu erklären, das heißt was wir jetzt machen müssen ist,
wir müssen ffmpeg sagen, liest ein package ein soweit du es brauchst und dann decode
das mit dem passenden decoder, das haben wir glücklicherweise schon alles gemacht, irgendwo
hier, einfach big brain decoding time, ich bin mir nicht mehr ganz sicher was ich da gemacht
habe, kannste es mal einrücken, reformat, continue, so, genau und jetzt muss ich das
ganze decoden, decoden, in den frame rein und das wars, gut gucken wir mal ob das ganze
jetzt funktioniert, ich vermute mal wir haben jetzt einen memory leak produziert, also das
sollte ausreichen dass der jetzt multithreadet unser gif decoded, wir werden wahrscheinlich,
nee wir werden ziemlich sicher noch nichts sehen, aber wir sehen dass es unterschiedliche
bilder gibt, das können wir gleich mal ausprobieren, frame, irgendwie timestamp, wts, genau, packet,
timestamps, so also das sollte von der idee jetzt funktionieren, machts nicht, ok, excellent,
warum nicht, decoder, ah weil ich das nirgendswo aufrufe, 0w, code frames, funktioniert das
jetzt, ok, funktioniert, so wir sehen auch dass die timestamps irgendwie sind ergeben
von einem gif, dann die timestamps sind 048 bis 36 und dann loopts wieder von vorne, also
das heißt wir haben 1, 2, 3, 4, 5, 6, 7, 8, 9, 10 bilder in dem gif, dann gehts wieder
von vorne los, also sprich das gif besteht aus 10 bildern, das ist halt der timestamp
von den einzelnen bildern, wie immer sich das errechnet, keine ahnung, so also das funkt,
das decoden funktioniert prinzipiell schonmal, ist halt ne endlos schleife, das heißt wir
werden das nie wieder los, deswegen hab ich eben auch hier gesagt ich brauch was zum cancelen
und dementsprechend läuft auch meine decoding schleife nicht für immer sondern nur bis
token is cancellation requested, also sprich wenn ich sage hier abbrechen dann soll er
auch aufhören die schleife laufen zu lassen, dann lasst es doch drin stehen, passt doch,
daher müssen wir jetzt heute nichts mehr großartig dazu schreiben, ich hab ja schon erklärt was
wir machen, so also jetzt haben wir das ganze hier, jetzt decoden wir das ganze hier und
jetzt hab ich glaub ich ne memory leak fabriziert wenn ich nicht komplett falsch liege, das
werden wir jetzt mal kurz kontrollieren ob wir ne memory leak fabriziert haben oder nicht,
schauen wir mal, ich vermute mal schon, das sieht doch ein bisschen nach memory leak aus,
gut ist ja aber auch klar ich lösche den kram ja auch nicht, ok doch wir müssen noch
was machen, wir müssen dem garbage collector sagen dass der aufräumen soll, es kann auch
sein dass wir gar kein memory leak haben, der einfach nicht aufräumt, doch wir haben
memory leak, ok ich glaube das liegt daran weil ich das nirgendswo freigebe also sprich
ich muss jetzt sagen bitte freigeben das was du hier eingelesen hast wenn wir durch sind
hier mit also sprich ffmpeg av frame unref und ffmpeg av packet unref, wo ist da noch
ein pointer reference ach mensch ffmpeg please, wo ist das problem jetzt schon wieder warum
nicht, achso ich hab es falsch rum, der langs ist kein wunder dass es nicht funktioniert,
wenn man das richt, so mal gucken ob das memory leak jetzt weg ist, das sieht auch schon mal
besser aus, er bleibt bei 53mb, außer dass der garbage collector grad absolut eskaliert
weil ich ihn jede schleife aufrufe und collecten lasse, aber zumindest kein memory leak mehr,
so wenn ich gc collect weg mache dann sieht es so aus als hätten wir memory leak, haben
wir aber nichts, sieht so nicht mal so aus, alles klar gut, ich hätte das eigentlich gedacht
es geht ein bisschen rauf, gut wunderbar dann stimmt das nicht was ich gesagt hab alles
gut also wir haben kein memory leak das ist schon mal fein, sehr gut, so und jetzt zum
eigentlichen decode, also decoded haben wir das bild hier, jetzt muss ich irgendwie das
bild von meinem decoder in das fenster reinbringen oder zumindest so tun erstmal, ich muss das
bild irgendwie aus meinem decoding thread in meinen ich würde gern was rendern thread
bekommen, so und das wollte ich über den channel machen, also maximal 10 frames im voraus
rendern, das heißt ich brauch da jetzt sowas wie channel, writer, write async, normalerweise
würde man das by the way so machen, aber nachdem diese metode unsafe ist kann ich kein async
und await verwenden in unsafe, deswegen müssen wir das jetzt ein bisschen anders machen,
new, video frame, was ich hoffe das funktioniert was ich gemacht hab, wait cleared gc eigentlich
den stuff aus der unsafe funktion, ja solang es managed memory ist macht es das schon,
wie gehen das, wie kann ich denn da warten, s-task, wait, da sagt microsoft das soll man
nicht so machen, aber mir fällt gerade ehrlich gesagt nichts anderes ein, weil wir können
es nicht der microsoft way machen, never used, warum, wir können es nicht im microsoft way
machen, weil wir unsafe verwenden und wenn da kein await drinne verwenden darf, get await
result, result ist das schöner als das, ich weiß nicht, ich lasse es jetzt einfach mal
so gucken ob es funktioniert, ja, warum ist das schöner, machst du das gleich oder, also
gut, also von der idee her kann ich jetzt hier ne schleife machen und dann darin rendern
und das sollte dann unabhängig voneinander laufen, ok ich sollte es vielleicht nicht
draw bitmap nennen, sondern draw, keine video frame oder so, so jetzt bin ich mal gespannt
ob das funktioniert, wie kriege ich denn jetzt raus überhaupt ob das funktioniert, ich gebe
hier einfach mal was drin aus, also frame, keine ahnung, data, mir egal, so, das sollte
jetzt unabhängig voneinander passieren wenn es funktioniert was ich gemacht hab, ja klappt,
warum ist das ein pointer 0, das kann eigentlich nicht stimmen, warum ist der pointer 0, der
zumindest funktioniert als multithreaded decoden schonmal, also der decoded hier unabhängig
von einem thread wo ich rendern will, 10 frames im voraus, get await result will rework stack
trace to take all, ich hab gar kein oi thread, sicher dass ich das verwenden soll, ja der
zebaro ist glaub ich mit matte im studium beschäftigt oder mit dem zebaro grill keine
ahnung, ok ich mach das jetzt mal was der chat sagt, also der chat sagt ich soll nicht
task aware sondern ich soll sagen get awaiter get result, also ok gut wenn der chat sagt
dass das besser ist dann glaub ich das dem chat, gucken wir mal ob das im release mode
funktioniert, tatsächlich funktioniert auch, ok chat hat recht ich mach das jetzt so, ist
das auf jithub, nee, moment was, hallo meine off topic frage ich hab jemanden auf youtube
gefunden der dieses interview liegt was sie hat mit dem dice team bezüglich dem neuen
battlefield, kann ich hier werbung für den machen weil wir sicher einige interessieren
da du ja wenig erzählen magst was hier drin, na gut ich darf dazu nichts erzählen wenn
es jemand anderes geleakt hat kann ich ja nichts für, kannst du ruhig machen das interessiert
mich nicht, was kannst du hier machen kannst du ruhig den video link posten da kann ich
dir sogar sagen ob das stimmt oder nicht, ob das legit ist, wobei du siehst es daran
ob das legit ist ist der chat mit dabei, wenn der chat mit dabei ist dann siehst du ab
und zu von mir mal dumme comments im chat, was lost, der lost hat garantiert nicht das
interview geleakt ups ich kenn den lost mit der hab ich letztens ein video aufgenommen
ist das willst du mich jibaden, zeig mal her, zeig mal her, da kommt jetzt wahrscheinlich
rick astley als link, achso ne die infos liegen kann der, das ist ok, das ist erlaubt, der
lost zeigt nix aus dem internen fhq, das ist ok, das ist alles in ordnung, du darfst das
event nicht mitschneiden, du darfst die infos aus dem event aber verwenden, das ist in
ordnung was er gemacht hat, ich hab sogar mit dem lost genau über dieses thema haben
wir uns da eine weile unterhalten, also das ist alles in ordnung, du darfst nur nicht
jetzt das event mitschneiden, hätte jetzt einer das event hochgeladen, ja das wäre
was anderes gewesen, ne so ist das alles in ordnung, ich hab ja auch immer im videos
sachen aus dem fhq erzählt, ok nochmal kurz big brain time, big brain time stimmt es
jetzt was ich hier so mache, also ich glaub schon, ich glaube schon dass das hier stimmt,
wir können ja mal kurz gucken ob das parallel läuft, wir gucken mal ob das parallel läuft,
also red sleep, ich lass das hier mal eine sekunde sleepen, frame in channel schreiben
bevor der frame unreft wird, ja mach ich ja, oder du meinst du der löscht das dann
wieder, ne der löscht das nicht, weil ich das gerappt habe in video frame und der macht
am anfang nen ref intern nochmal, also hier macht der nen ref drauf ffmpeg technisch
und gibt den dann am ende wieder frei, hier unreff ich den kram bloß, dass am ende der
ref counter auf 0 geht, was ich wahrscheinlich gar nicht machen müsste, was ich wahrscheinlich
gar nicht machen müsste, aber immerhin also dass das klappt auf jeden fall, programmierst
du immer ins zishab, ja das ist mein lieblingssprache, ich kann andere, ich hab irgendwo sogar ne tabelle
mit wo ich mal aufgeschrieben hab was ich kann, ja also die üblichen dinger, ich könnt
sogar was in java programmieren, hab ich aber kein bock drauf, krieg ich anfälle, ja also
meine lieblingssprachen sind einolch zishab und ruby, aber ruby ist ja nicht mehr angesagt,
ruby ist entgleist ja, ruby interessiert keinen mehr leider, so ich will mal kurz testen ob
das ganze jetzt wirklich multithreaded ist, also der sollte jetzt hier 10 bilder einlesen,
das testen wir jetzt mal ob das auch wirklich so ist, so der sollte unabhängig hier von
10 bilder einlesen, also gucken wir mal, sagen wir einfach mal channel, reader, count, gucken
wir mal ob das tut, ja ne 0, was, warum 0, das sollten noch eigentlich weiterhin 10 sein,
die logik muss mir jetzt mal einer erklären, warum 0, ich warte hier ne sekunde, ich lese
die garantiert nicht schneller als die gerendert werden, das verstehe ich net, ach 0 ist frame
data, moment, die anzeige stimmt ja gar nicht, 0w, wartet mal, ahja die anzeige stimmt überhaupt
nicht, ok alles klar, ok so, 10, der müsste jetzt aber weiter rendern, warum
rendert der nicht weiter, der sollte jetzt eigentlich weiter rendern, wartet mal, jetzt
bin ich verwirrt, der sollte eigentlich weiter rendern, der sollte jetzt einen durchgang machen
und dann den nächsten frame holen, oder kann das sein, dass das gar nicht funktioniert,
was mir der chat hier gesagt hat, dass das hier net geht, dass der chat mich gebadet hat,
der chat mich gebadet hat, das geht nicht chat, das geht nicht was ihr geschrieben habt,
ich weiß aber nicht warum, ich hab keine Ahnung warum das eine geht und das andere
nicht, kein Schimmer, aber jetzt funktionierts, jetzt funktionierts, guckt, das ist genau
in der Reihenfolge, also man sieht ja auch, dass es multithreaded ist, der macht 10 Stück
instant, mehr darf er nicht, mehr darf er nicht und dann liest er und nach jedem lesen
kommt ein neues, das ist, ok, das funktioniert richtig legit multithreaded, alles klar, wunderbar.
Wie findest du das vim plugin für die chatprints, das hab ich noch nicht verwendet ehrlich gesagt,
keine Ahnung, ich mag vim plugins in anderen editors nicht, ich mags auch in vias code
nicht und sonst wie, ich mag aber auch grafische vims nicht, also ein gvim ist überhaupt nicht
meins, auch wenn ich vim auf der kommando zeile mag, aber wenn mein vim nicht nach kommando
zeile aussieht, sondern nach gui, weiß nicht, mag ich das nicht, ok jetzt müssen wir mal
das gif malen, gut, also das gif decoden funktioniert, so draw video frame, jetzt muss, ach du scheiße
der direct x shit hier, wenn ich das schon sehe krieg ich anfälle, guckt euch das mal
an, das ist so massive pains champ, boah, ok wir machen da jetzt ne eigene klasse draus,
wir machen da jetzt ne eigene klasse draus, ich mach das, ich verschieb das gleich, mach
das mal hier innen drinnen, dass ich besser, public class, d, 2d, shit, oder stuff, komm
wir sind nett, ich lager das irgendwo hin aus, so also was brauchen wir denn da, boah
wie viel gedülns, ok vielleicht krieg ich das doch irgendwo hin, also den direct x kram
wieder einkommentieren, den direct x kram wieder einkommentieren, so das brauchen wir
auch, das brauchen wir auch, das ist so übertrieben unübersichtlich das zeug, das brauchen wir
auch, übrigens die frage steht immer noch, warum geht das, ich weiß es nicht, ich weiß
es bedeutlich, aber es geht, dann das wieder einkommentieren, ach du scheiße, das zeug
ist so abartig, ok, swap, ah hier unten render ich ja erst, ok, ok, und da kommt ja noch
mehr dabei, ok das ist nur das direct x setup was wir brauchen, das ist so geil, das rendert
noch gar nichts, das ist nur was man braucht, dass direct x überhaupt der meinung ist,
dass es funktioniert, ich guck mal ob es crasht, ok es crasht nicht, es funktioniert noch,
ist alles gut, so und jetzt können wir versuchen hier was zu renderen drin, jetzt können wir
versuchen was zu renderen, also wo render ich denn hier direct x mäßig was, ja begin
draw, color, gut, ich mal jetzt einfach mal einen roten, einen schwarzen, einen schwarzen
linden, einen gelbes fenster, oh gucken ob das funktioniert, begin draw, also damit stehe
ich ja echt auf kriegsfuß, und jetzt irgendwie swap chain, swap, ne wie ging das, swap, present,
so und die 0 das habe ich mir gemerkt, die 0 ist v-sync oder nicht v-sync, wenn ich
es mit einer 1 mache, dann wartet er auf v-sync, wenn ich es mit einer 0 mache schreibt er
so schnell wie geht, so, ach ich vergaß ein rotes fenster zu malen ist ja gar nicht so
doch glaube ich red, gucken wir ob wir jetzt ein rotes fenster kriegen, nein warum nicht,
wofür ruft er das überhaupt auf, achja ich mache es kaputt, ich rendere schon, ich rendere
schon bevor ich überhaupt das device angelegt habe, das ist die falsche reinfolge, so rum
jetzt gehts hoffe ich, nein, ok ich hatte gedacht es funktioniert jetzt, macht das was, ok von
der idee ruft er das auf, direct x bros, habe ich irgendwo was, mache ich irgendwas falsch,
was genau gemalt werden soll, naja ein rotes fenster, sonst nix, einfach ein rotes fenster,
war ich das falsch, macht das bestimmt falsch, weil das so eklig zu verwenden ist, hier begin
draw clear, boah ist das eklig, also gut also von der idee her stimmt das ja was ich da
mache, ok malen wir jetzt ein rotes rechteck, malst du mit clear, ja von der idee her sollte
clear ja alles komplett auf eine farbe setzen, also normalerweise macht man clear am anfang
und dann malt man oben drüber, also wenn man nicht übermalen will, so, warum geht das
jetzt hier nicht mehr, ach nee das ist rider was kein fehler anzeigt, sondern mir einfach
sagen will die farbe ist rot, sollte clear nicht alles transparent machen, nur mit transparent,
vermute ich mal, keine ahnung, so, mal weg, draw rectangle, so und zwar eine new rectangle
00 oder keine ahnung von 10 10, moment, yes, rectangle f alles klar, dass wir da mal haben,
unbedingt, raw rectangle ist mir zu billig, ich will rectangle f haben, so jetzt haben
wir hier, wir starten in dem fenster mit 10 pixel links oben, 200 pixel right, 200 pixel
hoch hohes rechteck, black brush, ok, so funktioniert das jetzt, wo ist das problem, warum geht
das nicht, ich habe irgendwas vergessen von meinem anderen zeug hier, nur dass ich nicht
mehr durchblicke was ich da gemacht habe, was habe ich denn vergessen, irgendwas habe
ich hier übersehen, direct x zeug, draw image, ja, ah, ich weiß was ich vergessen
habe, habe ich das händel vom fenster gesetzt, fuck habe ich, ach du scheiße, keine ahnung,
kein schimmer, warum kriege ich hier kein rectangle, warum nicht, skip, genau, rage
spit, so wir machen das jetzt mal hier ohne das thing, wir rendern das jetzt einfach mal
direkt hinten dran, ah der black brush ist nicht da, na dann, begin draw end draw, das
ist eigentlich richtig, dann present, das macht einfach nicht, das macht nichts, end
draw, present, vielleicht fehlt dick eigentlich net, ok, ich hab legit keine ahnung woran
das liegt, aber wir ignorieren das jetzt einfach mal und tun so als würde es funktionieren
und malen jetzt einfach mal ein bild, vielleicht geht das ja, zufälligerweise, vielleicht
haben wir ja klug, vielleicht geht das einfach mal ein bild malen, moment ich mach mal was
anderes nochmal hier, transparent, das hatte ich ja vorher auch so, transparent, wird das
noch aufgerufen, ja das geht nicht, wir ignorieren das jetzt einfach, wir ignorieren das, wir
gehen einfach, sagen einfach das funktioniert, das funktioniert und jetzt malen wir das mit
dem bild malen, also was zum teufel mach ich hier, create a bitmap, ok das pro durchlauf
zu machen ist doch auch schonmal fail, das kann doch net im sinne das erfinder sein was
ich hier bastel oder was ich hier gebastelt habe, gut wie dem auch sei ich kopier das
jetzt einfach, das war hier, das ist alles was ich zum rendern brauch, das kopier ich
da jetzt einfach rüber und dann probieren wir aus ob das funktioniert und wenn wir
glück haben klappt es und wirklich wahrscheinlich klappt es nicht, aber das sehen wir dann,
ich hab vergessen end draw aufzurufen, end draw, wo gibts end draw, begin draw, end draw
direkt über present, comp device commit fehlt, hab ich das, hab ich das übersehen, stimmt,
wo ist denn das hin, das hatte ich vorher noch, hab ich das gelöscht, moment, pass auf,
jit, jit magic, comp, commit, commit, warum hab ich nix gelöscht aber das, wie kann man
so bescheuert sein, gut dass wir zumindest irgendjemand im chat haben der weiß was ich
hier mache, weil ich weiß es nicht, warum hab ich das gelöscht, ist doch total hängen
geblieben, richtig, 3 hat time leute, leute, point, wo, emote, richtig, oi, chat hat immer
recht, nee, der chat hat heute schon gezeigt dass er nicht immer recht hatte, gut das heißt
wir denken jetzt, wir vermuten jetzt einfach mal das funktioniert, probieren wir das doch
mal aus, probieren wir das doch mal aus ob es funktioniert, wo ist denn hier, begin, also
begin draw, transparent, end draw, so und jetzt sagen wir hier einfach mal red, so und
jetzt mal gucken, ah, bam, also richtig massive big brain, wer auch immer das jetzt gerade
geschrieben hat, dass ich das vergessen hab, vielleicht wollte ich euch ja auch bloß testen
chat, ok es funktioniert, perfekt, rotes Fenster, dann können wir uns ja in der Sache
wiederholen, transparent, ich kommentiere das jetzt einfach mal ein, weil ich keine Ahnung
mehr genau hab was ich da gemacht hab das letzte mal, das ist auf jeden fall sehr ineffizient
weil ich alles pro durchgang neu anlege und das ist dumm, natürlich unsafe, was sonst,
machen wir hier irgendwas anderes, höhe, reite, was hat er jetzt schon wieder, uint
ist not int, komm int alles gut, dann halt kein uint, dann halt nen int, so warum eigentlich
nen int, warum braucht man wirklich nen int bei einer höhe, ich mein was ist denn minus
200 für ne höhe, ich verstehe wenn man sagt startpunkt ist minus 200, nach gott das macht
doch, doch das macht sinn, minus 200 ist dann nach links anstatt nach rechts oder, also
mal angenommen, mal angenommen ich sage ich starte von null null, also oben link, pixel
oben links oder sagen wir ich starte in der mitte, sagen wir ich starte in der mitte,
also null null und keine ahnung 800 oder so und ich male dann in rechteck, so wenn ich
200 mal 200 male, dann male ich quasi sowas hier, also ich mal paint, excellent, also wenn
ich 200 mal 200 male, dann male ich sowas, null ist oben links, deswegen sage ich ja
auch null und 800 oder so, so und wenn ich jetzt malen würde, 200 minus 200, dann würde
ich sowas hier malen oder, ja so paint kann das nicht, dann würde ich quasi sowas hier
malen, dann würde es ja ins negative gehen, gibt das sinn, kann das sein, weil ansonsten
wüsste ich nicht warum man ins verwendet für höhe breite, vielleicht auch gespielt
und vielleicht ist es auch nix von beiden und die waren einfach zu faul, so data, moment
das brauche ich doch hier gar nicht den kram, also create effect, ne das brauche ich nicht,
brauchen wir hier, new size, frame, breite, frame höhe, so frame data, jetzt funktioniert
natürlich, ach moment das ist ja schon in pointer, prominent, frame line size, haben
wir so schon, ok, breite, ok das ist big brain, quick muffs, da gehe ich einfach von aus,
stimmt nach wie vor, hoffe ich mal, da beste variablenamen überhaupt, so jetzt habe ich
hier so dinge wo ich mir ehrlich gesagt nicht mehr sicher bin wofür die da waren, reformat,
brauchen wir die jetzt oder brauchen wir die jetzt net, ne die habe ich nur reinkopiert
mal aus test, test vom, keine ahnung wir starten sie jetzt einfach mal, ok es funktioniert
nicht, das wäre jetzt ja auch zu schön gewesen, hätte einfach funktioniert, modge ist da,
rendert da überhaupt hier noch irgendwas, mal gucken, alter ich habe keine ahnung was
ich hier treibe, ne rip der rennt da gar nichts mehr, null das ist abgeschissen, vielleicht
soll ich das awaiten dass ich ordentliche exception kriege wenn er abkackt, war das
nicht eben noch lines, oh das kann sein, ja moment, ne ne ne ne das ist schon richtig
so, warte mal, das ergibt doch, das stimmt doch überhaupt nicht was ich da mache, das
ist doch alles leer, guck mal, ach bin ich aber schnell, guck mal, das wird nirgends
wo gesetzt, deswegen war das vorher auch immer null pointer, ich hab da nie was hingeschrieben,
das ist alles leer, das ist alles null, breite null, höhe null, lines heiß null, data null,
das kann ja nicht funktionieren, ja trycatch ist so ein ding, wenn du unmanaged code hast
dann funktioniert trycatch nicht immer und das ist komplett unmanaged zeugs unter der
haube, da steht überhaupt nichts drin, ok da muss ich mir jetzt noch was überlegen,
wie kriege ich die breite raus, die breite ist ja in wirklichkeit raw, also der ffmpeg
frame, breite, genau, so höhe ist ffmpeg frame höhe, linesize ist ffmpeg frame linesize
null, genau, das hatten wir nämlich vorher, das war das mit der null, was haben wir jetzt
noch, data, so und data ist dann das was wir vorher auch hatten, das ist raw und einfach
so, nee data war auch null, data null, das ganze muss man eben noch sagen, dass das ein
pointer ist, irgendwie, so ok, achtung, bam, der refrescht nicht, ach nee ich habe noch
ein sleep 1 drin, ich habe noch ein sleep 1 drin, slow motion parrot, aber es funktioniert
schon mal, oh das sleep raus, ok das heißt ich kann den ganzen shit hier rausschmeißen
von den ganzen eklichen kram vom letzten mal weg, so perfekt, den kram auch raus, das sieht
schon, das sieht jetzt schon deutlich aufgeräumter aus den ganzen kram als das letzte mal, so
jetzt machen wir hier mal den sleep raus und jetzt, bam, jawoll, da flutscht es, ich hab's
geadded das emote, da flutscht es, aber was sagt die auslastung, oh, oh, oh, oh, wir
haben gerade 10 gigabyte ram ausgelastet, haben wir leaked champ irgendwo, mal gucken
wie die cpu auslastung ist, ah das ist nice, guck mal jetzt haben wir viel höhere auslastung
als vorher, das heißt das ist jetzt ein bisschen multithreaded zumindest, ich bin begeistert,
multithreaded champ, also es ist natürlich sinnlos ein gif so schnell zu rendern, ich
muss jetzt noch gucken wie viel fps hat das gif und es dann realistisch, also in dem fall
muss ich 40 millisekunden warten, dass das gif in korrekter geschwindigkeit läuft, guck
also jetzt sieht das auch schon besser aus, sieht das normal aus, aber wir haben irgendwo
glaube ich einen memory leak, das muss ich jetzt gerade noch mal ausprobieren, wir machen
jetzt was was wir sonst nicht macht aber ich will einfach wissen ob es nicht daran liegt
dass der garbage collector einfach nicht collectet, doch das liegt daran dass der garbage collector
nicht collectet, der garbage collector ist zu pepo fett, der collectet zu langsam, warum
macht der denn sowas, kann man dem garbage collector, weiß das jemand, kann man dem sagen
ey collecte mal ab einem gigabyte ram, weil ich mein jetzt mal ernsthaft, man sagt ja
immer garbage collector nicht manuell collecten lassen und sowas, aber ich mein, aber ich
mein, aber ich mein es kann doch nicht sein, dass der garbage collector erst bei was weiß
ich wie viel gigabyte ram sich mal dazu überreden lässt zu collecten oder, ich mein wir brauchen
8g, 9g ram, 10g ram, mal gucken ab wann der collectet, 11g ram, 12g ram, ah das ist aber
nett, das ist aber nett, dass er ab 12g ram erst mal erst mal pause macht, 12, also ich
finde, oh oh oh wiss ich dachte das wars jetzt schon, also ich finde, ich finde das kann
man sich schon mal gönnen, das kann man sich für den gif, für den gif player schon mal
gönnen 13,3gigabyte ram, also keine schande, gut investierte 13,3gigabyte ram ja finde
ich auch, also es ist ja fast wie ein chrome mit 100, 100 tabs auf, also der garbage collector
hat auch gar keinen bock zu collect kann das sein, der denkt sich so, wo ist das problem
reicht doch, ok wie kann ich dem garbage collector sagen, guck mal das ist, das ist max generation,
ne der hat erst einmal versucht zu collecten, ey guck mal das juckt dir nett, das juckt
dir nett, das kann doch nicht den ernst oder, manged language by the way, vielleicht hätte
ich, Leute Leute soll ich euch mal was sagen, vielleicht hätte ich es doch in C++ machen
sollen, gut dann wären wir jetzt nicht soweit gewesen, bloß nicht alter C++ ich hätte anfälle
bekommen, ich wäre durchgedreht wenn ich das hätte in C++ machen müssen sage ich
euch, manged language unsafe keyboard, ja moment das eine hat ja mit dem andere nichts
zu tun, ja das hier sagt ja einfach nur ich darf rumsauen wie ich will aber manged memory
übrigens brauche ich das an selfie an der stelle gar nicht aber manged memory soll er
trotzdem handeln, mein eigenen unmanaged memory das handle ich ja sogar, ok was ich machen
könnte ist tatsächlich mich selbst um das aufräumen kümmern und nicht der garbage
collector, also ich könnte anstatt so einen garbage collector destructor oder finalizer
zu verwenden könnte ich das wirklich selbst machen, also das ist ja dann relativ einfach
dann würde ich dann würde ich sowas sagen wie, so dann packe ich das einfach da rein
das kommt weg und ich sag hier drinnen, moment hier unten sag ich dann frame dispose so und
jetzt sollten wir auch kein memory leak mehr haben aber auch kein memory leak mehr easy
ich dachte mir halt wir lassen das den garbage collector übernehmen zu schnell ne das ist
genau richtig das sind jetzt ungefähr so 1500 fps ich finde das ist genau richtig für das
gif wird langsam mehr ja ne ne ne das passt schon das passt schon manche sachen brauchen
erst ein bisschen aber das das das das ist ja ne ne guck das passt schon ach jetzt hast
du collected das ist ja nett das ist ja nett das war von 140 auf 116 mb 100 garbage collected
ist gut aber von 13 gigabyte mal was collecten das muss man nicht
hier ich hab den moment ich hatte es doch eben auf ich glaube ich weiß woran das liegt
warum das nicht collected wird weil moment ich hab das ja hier über einen destructor
gemacht so und intern ist es ja so jede klasse mit die mit jede klasse mit finalizer wird
vom garbage collector erstmal nicht im ersten durchlauf collected so das finalizer klassen
vom garbage collector collected werden müssen irgendwelche ja nur bill gates weiß es keine
ahnung bedingungen eintreten vielleicht dass der ram zu voll wird oder so keine ahnung
also finalizer klassen werden ein bisschen anders bannen aber das geht also normalerweise
also dass das prinzipiell funktioniert hat man ja gesehen wenn ich gc collect von hand
mache dann geht es ja und das ist bei 13,3 gigabyte nicht mehr geworden ist das spricht
auch dafür dass der gar nicht doof ist und das intern schon weiter verwendet aber halt
diesen 13 gigabyte block behält was halt mega hängen geblieben ist weil ich will kein 13
gigabyte großen gift player haben also 116 ich finde 116 mb für den fenster mit gift
player und bis in direkt x geschiss ist ist schon in ordnung genau die gelben punkte zeigen
an wo er collectet es stimmt aber man weiß ja nicht ob er nur eine normale collection
macht von allen first generation wie heißt der kram first generation von allen first
generation objekten oder ob er eine komplette collection macht wo auch finalizer drin sind
also finalizer ist quasi also das habe ich mal gelesen wenn du ein objekt hast mit finalizer
dann ist das quasi wie ein second generation objekt im garbage collector er collecte das
nicht mit den normalen sachen sondern erst zu einem anderen zeitpunkt und was auch immer
keine ahnung microsoft logik ist mir auch wurscht so ist so ist eigentlich fast noch
besser ich ich ich ich dispose das einfach von hand am ende und dann ist ruhe das ist
auch gut ich habe mir halt gedacht hey managed language wir können das den garbage collector
handeln lassen aber bevor ich den 13 gigabyte gift player habe dann collecte ich das lieber
von hand was ist denn chain law ich sehe da in deiner message nix wie viele emotes denn
noch ich glaube von allen emoten vorschlägen haben wir das letzte mal habe ich das letzte
ich glaube die letzten zwanzig ffz emotes sind von dir ach nee du meinst neuesten emote
vorschlag für mein für mein ein emotes ach so soll denn das sein
leute das müsst ihr mir erklären erklärt mir das mal chat erklärt mir das wenn ihr
mir das erklärt so dass ich es auch lustig finde dann mache ich das rein
ok was ist das origin ok das zusammengesetzt aus cope und opium
was ist denn cope was ok wenn man sich mit schwierigen sachen
auseinandersetzt ok das heißt ok wenn ich das jetzt richtig verstehe wenn was richtig
in die hose gegangen ist setzt man sich quasi cope um auf dass es einem wieder besser geht
also das fiktionale droge setzt man sich dann auf dass er wieder betten hinein ja was
denn jetzt jepp oder nein ich sehe schon ich sehe schon dass da bin ich zu alt für jetzt
wo was auch immer stark geklickt habe wollte ich nicht wenn was kacke ist aber du sagst
schon ok das ist quasi bis es fein dass es dieses fein bloß bloß anders oder ok dann
dann dann verstehe ich aber ich wusste also wir können dieses emote nehmen aber das müssen
wir noch ein bisschen anpassen das sieht mir noch ein bisschen zu paint paintig aus kannst
du das noch irgendwie schöner machen dann nehme ich mache ich direkt rein dann nächsten
stream aber das muss eigentlich das muss noch ein bisschen professioneller aussehen ich
kann dir nicht sagen was aber es sieht irgendwie ziemlich weiß ich zusammen gewusstet aus
vielleicht das blaue die blauen kabel so dass man sieht wenn das so klein das erkennt guck
mal das erkennst du doch nett wenn das emote klein ist das emote ist ungefähr auf der
größe im chat das erkennt man nicht gut gut dass wir das jetzt auch mal geklärt haben
jetzt weiß ich bescheid macht mein aktuelles video so auf youtube ich habe sehr ich lasse
meine eigenen videos immer einmal durchlaufen weil gut für den algorithmus was sagen denn
die leute ausbildung beginnt exzellent so leute heute sind wir doch so ganz schön relativ
weit gekommen wir haben diesen ganzen shit also ich mein blub und temp müssen wir noch
aufräumen wir lagern das nächste mal das direkt x zeug aus aber das war heute schon
mal echt gut wir machen wir machen übrigens das lieb mal wieder rein dass das nicht immer
so hektisch aussieht sondern normal also das war doch heute schon mal richtig richtig gut
wir machen das ganze jetzt multithreaded das doch schon mal nice und wir haben das decoding
von dem gif komplett hier raus das heißt das nächste mal lagern wir noch hier in diese
direkt 2d stuff klasse das ganze direkt x zeug aus und dann sieht das doch fast fast lesbar
aus das video von heute ist nicht super beliebt das liegt aber auch daran weil es einfach
nicht so viele leute anspricht das betrifft ja erstmal nur leute die ausbildung machen
gemacht anfangen also anfangen gerade machen oder vielleicht interessiert sind weil sie
die mal gemacht haben ja alternativ macht man es wie hart verrat erstmal
harzen bei stimmt ja bei ihm überhaupt nicht ist das eine wiederholung ja das ist eine
wiederholung ich bin eigentlich schon im bettke ich bin nicht mehr an bettke
es ist eigentlich was eigentlich im friseur ist der ist ja und scheine ich nope der frazier
mit seinen weep games i weep frisier äh moment was was chat sekunde was mich interessiert
kannst du mal checken ob der mehr objekte erstellt als der gcf wie soll ich das machen
du kannst es doch bei dir nachbauen machen objekte objekte mit finalizer was memory belegt
und gucken ob er es freiräumt oder nicht ja ich weiß jetzt nicht wie ich das checken
soll wo ist das limit hast du schon eine world durch ich hab nicht mal weiter gespielt es
ist halt äußerst repetitive dem game fehlt so gut wie jeglicher inhalt zumal sie versuchen
ja ein bisschen auf die pvp schiene zu gehen aber das ist finde ich nicht konsequent nachdem
auch alle fraktionen in der gleichen welt spielen und du zusätzlich noch sagen kannst
ob die flaggen willst für pvp oder nicht ich weiß nicht es ist irgendwie ich meine
in bdo ist es ansatzweise ein ähnliches system aber in bdo kannst du immer noch force jemand
killen wenn er dir zu sehr auf den sack geht und du hast deutlich mehr zu tun freust du
dich noch einfach game auf ja ja es dauert auch gar nicht lang ich freue mich extrem
auf das da das kommt im 2 september ist das glaube ich release date ja da freue ich mich
richtig drauf kingmaker war schon nice auch wenn die steam noobs das wieder nicht gecheckt
haben die steam noobs bei kingmaker die haben geschrieben oh nein das spiel ist viel zu
schwer ich sterbe in der ersten höhle und der npc der vor der höhle steht sagt ihr
wortwörtlich nehmen explosive also nehmen bomben mit gegen die gegen die mücken da
in der höhle und die leute machen das nicht versuchen die mücken schwer zu killen und
sterben und schreiben dann auf steam und nein das spiel ist zu schwer just suck developer
ja da freue ich mich richtig drauf das kommt ja auch wie gesagt in einem monat raus aber
nächsten monat werde ich erstmal 37 also noch mehr boomer als jetzt schon wisst ihr
eigentlich ich sagte zwar ist aber wisst ihr eigentlich dass boomer für meine generation
überhaupt nicht die korrekte bezeichnung ist boomer sind leute die von 1948 bis 1965
geboren sind ich bin eigentlich kein boomer und ich bin
auch kein zoomer ich bin die generation dazwischen die richtigen zoomer sind übrigens eigentlich
auch gar nicht generation z sondern eher generation alpha das sind die die ab 2012 geboren sind
bis 2025 das sind die richtigen das sind ich bin boomer genau ich war millennial ich bin
boomer wo wir wirklich welche dachten dass die dass die welt uns das war echt hängen
geblieben boomer ist eine lebenseinstellung ja gut das stimmt in der heutigen zeit wundert
mich ja auch nix du kannst ja auch laut laut twitter laut twitter kannst du ja auch als
20 jähriger chinese weißer alter mann sein twitter wenn ihr mir das nicht glaubt twitter
erklärt euch schon wie das funktioniert macht euch keine gedanken das ist laut twitter
überhaupt kein problem ohne probleme möglich easy also kann man natürlich auch boomer sein
wenn man nicht in der boomer generation geboren ist das ist ganz klar ja aber das war doch
heute relativ erfolgreich das hat gut gut funktioniert wollen wir outro outro musik
machen bei 5 minuten habe ich noch 5 minuten habe ich noch produktiv ja war gar nicht schlecht
gleich spätge gleich gleich spätge ich fand es auch cool dass wir das hier mal mit channels
ausprobiert haben weil wie gesagt channels ist ja neu seit dotnet keine ahnung 3.1 oder
so dotnet core 3.1 also der vorgänger von dotnet 5 nicht zu verwechseln mit dotnet framework
4.8 also microsoft benahmung sind ja schon immer richtig gut gewesen trifile gibt es
doch irgendwelche interessanten dinger die heute passiert sind aber blizzard ist ja richtig
die scheide die kacke am dampfen habt ihr das mitgekriegt die wollen jetzt streiken
bei blizzard jetzt also blizzard ist vorbei da ist jetzt da ist jetzt wirklich richtig
richtig die die kacke am dampfen aber die sind ja auch doof die sind die sind ja auch
die sind ja auch total hängen geblieben also nach dieser geschichte und nach der klar
also erst mal die klage und dann nach der nach dieser ganzen geschichte dann auch diese
komische mail zu veröffentlichen dass es doch eigentlich gar nicht so stimmt beziehungsweise
dass dass man so viel dafür dafür tut ist typisches management gelaber aber das ist
eh so ein so ein ich sag so ein so ein so ein so ein rhetorik trick den manager manager
leute und oder auch pressesprecher gerne versuchen ja also irgendjemand kommt und sagt leute
eure firma hat scheiße gebaut weil sie a und b gemacht hat dann kommt dann da kommt eine
offizielle presseerklärung und da steht dann drinne ich bin stolz darauf in einer firma
zu sein bei der a und b niemals ein thema ist gewesen ist oder niemals niemals passieren
kann du machst einfach eine presseerklärung wo genau das gegenteilige drin steht von dem
was man dir vorwirft obwohl obwohl sogar zwar auf der hand liegt dass es so ist aber blizzard
ist wirklich ja die haben keine gewerkschaft soweit ich weiß in den usa bei blizzard aber
die wollen morgen oder so blizzard streik die wollen morgen genau die wollen morgen
irgendwie streiken
hier mittwoch das heißt was jetzt passieren wird ist folgendes das management von blizzard
wird jetzt versuchen die sachen klein zu reden und irgendwelche aus dem ermel gezauberten
beruhigungs sachen zu erzählen sie haben ja in dem in dem letzten statement hat blizzard
ja auch erzählt sie hätten jetzt was haben sie geschrieben anti anti mobbing und diskriminierungskurse
und sowas da habe ich mich als letztes mal schon gefragt wie man sich sowas vorstellen
soll ja als ist es den leuten diese scheiße verhalten nicht klar als geht irgendjemand
von diesen leuten in den kurs und man sagt ihm hier übrigens dass du hast dich da nicht
gut verhalten da sagte ach wirklich das wusste ich ja gar nicht leute die andere leute abfacken
die machen das absichtlich weil sie spaß dran haben und die wissen das die machen das
ja absichtlich weil sie spaß dran haben die gehen auch nicht in den kurs und und sagen
danach hoja das habe ich noch nie so gesehen ja jetzt ist jetzt werde ich ein anderer menschen
nach dem kurs was ein schwachsinn
ja wahrscheinlich schon aber bei den meisten ist es so die meisten die auf der arbeit leute
abfacken die wissen sehr wohl dass das dass sie das machen und die haben spaß dran du
hast bestimmt den ein oder anderen der sich da noch nie gedanken darüber gemacht hat
und es nicht checkt aber die meisten wissen das bei warcraft 1 war noch alles ok es war
bei blizzard lange alles ok erst seit die ganzen stonks leute da am start sind also ich
würde sagen das letzte wenn man mal auf watch außen vor lässt was ja so ein abfallprodukt
war von einem mmo was sie machen wollten das letzte gute game was blizzard gemacht hat
ist wings of liberty overwatch auch aber auf auf watch war ja so ein so ein ok vielleicht
hartstone noch hartstone lasse ich mir auch noch gefallen hartstone war ein interner versuch
von einem kleinen team ob man nicht irgendwie mal was innovatives wieder machen kann aber
ansonsten wir haben hartstone raus 2014 ja dann sagen wir hartstone dann danach konntest
vergessen ist eigentlich ganz gutes game gewesen aber das war ja ein unfall also in dem produkt
dass das rausgekommen ist wirst du wenn es rauskommt overwatch 2 ich denke ich werde
es mir mal angucken aber also nach aktuellem stand wird overwatch 2 ja in nächster zeit
nicht erscheinen und das was ich bisher gesehen habe rechtfertigt für mich nach wie vor kann
overwatch 2 jeff ist weg hat schon seinen grund der hatte keinen bock mehr auf den kack
was auch immer der intern war der alte blizzard mitgründer ist weg links ist weg ich habe
schon vergessen wie er heißt dass das multitalent von blizzard der voice geaktet hat grafiken
gemacht hat die stories geschrieben hat wie ist er denn der bekannteste blizzard typ ich
komme nicht auf den namen chris metzen jetzt habe ich es wieder genau der ist auch weg
ist ja nichts mehr da der ist noch da ja also das glaubt nicht dass das was das was wird ganz
ehrlich das ist nicht schlecht aber ich habe so viele emotes die wir kaum benutzen ich
muss die immer aus hallo wo ist die emote anzeige warum habe ich hier keine keine ffz
emote anzeige was ist das problem bei der twitch ist doch alles an weg hat hat kein bock
mehr aber andere rechte habe ich noch vielleicht muss man eingeloggt sein dazu keine ahnung
ich meine ich habe wie viel sind das 80 80 80 bett twitch tv emotes oder so 1 2 3 4 5
6 7 pro zeile 1 2 3 4 5 6 7 8 9 10 11 12 zeilen alter ah ungefähr 80 80 bett twitch tv
emotes und dann bestimmt nochmal 1 2 3 4 5 6 7 1 2 3 4 5 6 7 nochmal nochmal mindestens
um die 40 ffz emotes also das ist die emotes verwendet gar keiner mehr cac buy ist underrated
cac buy brauchen wir jetzt gleich wieder wenn ich off gehe also leute heute war äußerst
produktiver nicer progas stream da kam sogar was richtig sinnvolles bei raus ich mache
ich heute letzte mal ihr wolltet ihr wolltet ich mache ich wieder ich mache ich wieder
outro outro musik ja das ist ja bettge musik oh was ist das das müssen wir uns glaube
ich angucken dann am sonntag fachinformatik system integration 2011 also moment zeigt
hier was hat er auf windows windows in windows oh das ist big brain das ist vm windows in
windows mit windows krasse scheiß bin 17 jahre alt und macht die ausbildung zum fachinformatiker
in fachrichtung system integration hier bei der firma handmann stehm integration es klingt
es klingt ein bisschen ein bisschen schwebisch zu meinen aufgaben gehört die konfiguration
und die installation von system sowie die betreibung und die wartung von it system da
ich zum großteil in der it infrastruktur beschäftigt bin lerne ich anwenderprobleme zu lösen zum
beispiel in der it hotline jawoll endkundensupport beste da hat jeder bock drauf dauert drei
jahre danach habe ich noch die möglichkeit mich weiterzubilden zum beispiel mit dem techniker
fachwirt ja das juck kein fachwirt ist also ehrlich gesagt vielleicht weiß ich ob ihr
einen kennt ich kenne niemand der die weiter bildungs ihk geschichten gemacht hat ich kenne
nur leute die nach der ausbildung gesagt haben ich gehe eventuell noch was studieren aber
ich habe noch keinen gesehen gibt es bestimmt der die der diese diese weiterführen ihk
abschlüsse gemacht hat keine ahnung oder sogar mit einem studium nice sound abmischung
ok ok da kann da finde ich mich jetzt sogar ein bisschen wieder alles ibm notebook erkennt
man diesen trackpad in der mitte wo er gerade seinen finger drauf hat falls es eins ist
was ist ein kabeltester ne keine ahnung aber immerhin das sieht relativ ordentlich aus
entgegen zu dem wie es bei uns früher im etat ausgesagt jede menge glasfaser stellts
sc stecker muss glasfaser sein irgendwelche letztwerk
die musik ist die gute alte ihr glaubt es mir immer nicht wenn ich sage server haben
heute im rechten zentrum immer noch vga das vollkommen normal glaube auch nicht dass
es das ist ein dl 380 das nicht nicht nicht nicht nicht der neueste dl 380 falls ein dl
380 ist aber neu genug die am vga ist immer noch am start
warum genau muss jemand neben ihm stehen beim glasfaserkabel einstecken also ich gehe davon
aus als hubi kann das alleine glasfaserkabel einstecken wenn es ihm mal gezeigt hat also
das ist jetzt ja nicht dass das wahnsinns skills erfordert würde ja das heißt er darf
den ganzen scheiß machen den alle anderen auch super wahrscheinlich ist es da wirklich
nicht schlecht dass das was ich mich schon als vollwertiges mit in unserer it was mir
bis jetzt am besten gefallen hat ist das aufbauen von netzwolken in der it ja da wird dann auch
gleich das theoretische wissen netzwerk netzwerk kram ist ist echt spannend aus der berufsschule
null ganz bestimmt der lernt das erst wie man es richtig macht und dann in der berufsschule
noch mal wie man es verkehrt macht waren die kindern tage so entstand dann auch gleich
eine gewisse freundschaft unter den azubis alter welche wer hat den sound abgemischt
was bin ich sehend sysco konfig port sysco port konfig ne was sieht man da leute habt
ihr einen plan das ist übrigens kein IBM er meint er ist eingehackt ja ist das ist
das port konfig vielleicht könnte schon sein oder auch nicht boah da hätte ich keinen
bock drauf alter arbeitsplätze einrichten hör mal auf es gibt so ein paar dinge da
könnte da könntest du das würde ich im leben da könnte mir die sonst was bezahlen
das würde ich nicht machen das ist hotline und das ist turnschuhe arbeitsplätze einrichten
habe ich jetzt dein interesse am beruf des informatikers für systemintegration geweckt
um ehrlich zu sein danach hätte ich die ausbildung nicht angefangen nach endkundensupport an
der hotline und arbeitsplätze einrichten klick dich rein wir freuen uns auf deine bewerbung
ne bloß nicht
der typ sieht aus wie der tagschausprecher bloß dass das net ist
das ist ja nichts neues wir wissen das ja schon lange dass der kreativ ist wissen wir
auch also sich neue neuen beschiss ausdenken naja gut egal outro musik
also leute wir sehen uns bis nächsten stream cu
bye
Das war's für heute.
Vielen Dank für's Zuschauen.